when Kobe Ryan entered the Boise
courtroom Tuesday 18 jurors watched as
his mother Lori velodabel mouthed the
words my baby before the 27 year old
took the witness stand then they heard
an extremely tense jailhouse phone call
between the two you think you can hide
from me
seven-year-old J.J valo and 16 year old
Tyler Ryan went missing in September of
2019 roughly eight months later their
decomposed remains were discovered
buried on the property of her new
husband Chad davil
my siblings and my whole family my dad
are everyone is gone except for you and
you're in jail because of this ripped my
heart out and you ripped out